treatment options for cancer includes
surgery radiation therapy and
chemotherapy you may receive one or a
combination of these treatments
depending on the size of tumor whether
it has spread and whether or not you
would like to be able to have children
you have several surgical options
depending on the type and stage of the
cancer during early stage one a your
surgeon may perform con ization to
remove a cone-shaped piece of the cervix
one example of Kaunas ation called leap
or loop electrosurgical excision
procedure uses a thin wire heated by
electricity to remove the tissue during
later stage 1a and 1b your surgeon may
perform a radical tre colectomy to
preserve your uterus if you want to be
able to have children later the surgeon
removes the cervix an upper part of the
vagina and places a stitch at the lower
end of the uterus to act as an
artificial internal opening of the
cervix during early stage 1a your
surgeon may perform a total hysterectomy
removing the uterus and cervix during
later stage 1a and 1b your surgeon may
perform a radical hysterectomy removing
the cervix the tissue around the cervix
the uterus and part of the vagina during
either a total or radical hysterectomy
your surgeon may remove other tissues
such as the fallopian tubes ovaries or
lymph nodes as necessary if the cancer
recurred your surgeon may perform pelvic
exaggeration removing all the organs and
tissues as in a radical hysterectomy
plus the pelvic lymph nodes bladder
vagina rectum and colon depending on
where cancer has spread radiation
therapy or radiotherapy uses high-energy
rays to kill cancer cells in the treated
area only
external beam radiation therapy is
directed of the cancers location from a
machine outside your body
brachytherapy or internal radiation
therapy is directed at the cancers
location from a device placed inside
your body chemotherapy
a systemic treatment uses drugs to stop
the growth of the cancer cells by either
killing them or inhibiting their cell
division once the drugs enter the
bloodstream they can travel and reach
cancer cells throughout the body